right now we are continuing to learn
more and more about the so-called
stimulus package
that passed congress last night because
as the president explained
it appears to have everything in it
except real direct aid for struggling
american families
the 5500 page 2.3
trillion dollar omnibus package includes
things like
establishing two new branches of the
smithsonian museum
creating national standards for the
horse racing industry
and making illegal streaming a felony
and there's more
like 10 million dollars for quote gender
programs
in pakistan hundreds of millions in
other foreign aid
and even a statement of policy regarding
the succession
of the reincarnation of the dalai lama
but for americans suffering the current
package includes a mere one-time
600 direct payment and even worse is
that lawmakers passed one of the most
expensive and egregious pieces of
legislation
ever without actually reading it
it's degrading it's disgusting and
demeaning but unfortunately not at all
surprising of course
and exactly what we've come to expect
from the entrenched political swamp
just listen to congresswoman tulsi
gabbard and senator rand paul explaining
their opposition take a look
hey everybody i just got back from
having
voted on the house floor on this massive
spending bill
i voted against it and i wanted to tell
you why
first of all this bill was over 5500
pages long
we received the text of this bill at
approximately 2
30 this afternoon and we're told we'd
have to go and vote on it
just a few hours later i've been here
long enough to see
how provisions are snuck into these
bills
in literally in the dark of night
without any announcement without
telling anyone what is in it and then
rushed through
in the manner that we have just seen
tonight the monster spending bill
presented today
is not just a deficits don't matter
disaster
it is everything republicans say they
don't believe in
to so-called conservatives who are quick
to identify the socialism of democrats
if you vote for this spending montrosity
you are no better
now congressman andy biggs echoed those
remarks
tweeting quote after days of back room
negotiations and only a handful of hours
to read the six
thousand page legislation the house
passed the omnibus and covet 19 spending
bill tonight
congress continues to fail the american
people and bankrupt our grandchildren's
future
now the bill is so bad that it's
bringing together
senator ted cruz and congresswoman
ocasio-cortez
in opposition to the bill and get this
the backlash is so severe
that it's causing democrats to lose
faith in their own leadership
maybe it's about time as a new poll
released this morning finds that just a
slim majority of democrats
want pelosi to stay on a speaker so let
me be clear here
after months of crippling lockdowns
months of conflicting public health
guidance
and months of stonewalling from nancy
pelosi
we're left with what is just another
massive government handout to special
interests
foreign governments and in the words of
speaker pelosi
crumbs for those who need it more than
ever
the american people it's reckless it's
reprehensible
but right in line with what has become
all too common
on capitol hill